well I did say I'd throw video game
reviews in the mix and I figure I might
as well start off with sim God
civilization be oh it's five crazy
Romans alright so if any of you out
there have ever played a civilization
game you already know that no other game
in history turns the phrase just one
more move into the biggest 12-hour lie
like a civilization game I mean the
concept is pretty simple thanks Simpson
but an entire civilization you build it
up from the ancient era you take it
through the future era develop
diplomacy's how you want culture how you
like military might because in these
games that's always awesome I want a
military conquest victory with Gandhi
and a diplomatic victory with Ramses you
can do that in this you have quite a few
civilizations to choose from like Rome
China Japan the list goes on and the
civilizations are unique they have the
unique stat buffs and a unique units
that only they can make it helps you out
depending on which victory you want to
go towards in which case Gandhi can win
a military domination victory funny
enough Hitler's not the leader of
Germany I'm not saying he should be I'm
saying France has a Napoleon in
Civilization 5 and when I say the phrase
military conquest leaders of Germany who
do you think of yeah Bismarck the guy
they have in Civilization five who else
what I think of going to be weird I
guess Hitler winning the diplomatic
victory might piss some people off who
are still alive like today so Bismarck
it is I really like how they have the
hex based playing field now instead of
the squares they can't even imagine
playing civilization with squares
anymore and I personally think it's
easier to get a diplomatic victory I
mean before you go for a diplomatic
victory to have no military and just be
like hey Oh what are you guys doing here
good you need to leave now I'm not gonna
lie this is this is pretty awkward um
yeah we're gonna take your land because
there's no way you can stop us
you need to leave my land
you're free to try to stop us if you
want there's nothing wrong with dying
from the stealth bomber that's flying
above you right now but that's a very
nice rock you have in your hand I gotta
say very good weapon and now you can go
for a diplomatic victory and still have
kind of a military so I like that it
seems they made the game a little
simpler to play but it's not like dumb
what I don't like about the game is the
interaction between you and the other
civilizations like I wanted a Bioware
game you know I wanted tears of dialogue
that just
felt like it actually mattered this you
have like do you want to trade with me
do you want to scheme against that
person and do you want to go to war
there's not much there's like five
options it always seems like when you
ask them to do stuff they're like no and
when they ask you you're like yeah I'll
do that you know cuz it's a mechanic of
the game and I want to be a douche bag
and scheme behind their bags and vine
eyes like I asked Japan if they wanted
to team up against Napoleon and they
were like no we don't want no that
doesn't interest us and then three turns
later they were like I'm in do you want
to team up against Napoleon I really
think we should weigh to make me feel
like my dialogue matters in the game
teaming up against viva la douche like
Tetris I will be playing this game for
years non-stop just like I have for the
past seven days and of course after you
win your victory in the game you can
still keep playing so you can
concentrate on the deeper aspects of
diplomacy
you know you do it too and you know it
is awesome so go get civilization 5 or
goddamn Santa Claus are both gonna punch
kittens just in bags just punch them and
it'll be your fault hours will seem like
minutes you will get nothing done around
your house I am convinced that
civilization 5 will contribute to the
most amount of lack of productivity then
when pot first sprang on the scene but
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more than click right
here to see more
[Music]